the difference between the two Mulan
films in the first one she had to be
Innovative and crafty because she was
smaller than the rest of them and in the
second one she was better than all of
the men immediately because she had like
estrogen I've heard from critical
Drinker where he's commenting about Star
Wars right he doesn't need to learn
anything she has the Jedi Powers I think
he basically attributes it to this new
wave of hyper feminism in Hollywood
where the female characters are always
more competent than the male characters
and it's patronizing for instance if you
think about an entire generation of
girls now who are growing up with these
kinds of female leads maybe the initial
experience is them being told if you're
female you can achieve whatever you want
the second reflect of this are all of
the heroes never had to encounter
difficulties any difficulty that you do
encounter in your life is due to
something structural and you should
complain about the world as opposed to
change yourself or adapt to it according
to Manisha baggage claim it makes an
entire generation a fragile narcissist
women